bonjour sinimalé damien paysagiste le
conseil pratique des limites et massif
et 5 me conseille à zatta vont défaire
massif choisir l'emplacement par rapport
à l'ensoleillement et choisit aussi les
plantes par rapport au climat
manu va utiliser de piqué et un cordeau
une pelle bêche une pique à cannes
ensuite pour eux égalisé la tête je vais
utiliser un râteau adam traditionnel
selon les goûts selon envie on peut
faire le quart et le triangle toutes
sortes de formes même des massifs
surélevées ou pas faut laisser son
imagination par les voilà
mais là je vais mettre le point le point
central afin de faire le traçage avec le
compas
donc on peut utiliser de la chaux pour
eux bien marquer le traçage faudra
appeler décaissés sur 20 cm de
profondeur afin que les plantes puisse
s'enraciner plus facilement un petit
conseil pratique ou carussi d'intérêt
bien d'année moi je conseille faire un
arrosage une à deux heures avant enfin
de
de relater un peu plus meuble est plus
facile à décaisser
petits conseils pratiques et des volants
durable jeudi ces zones là que se trouve
dans son jardin et commerciaux massifs
l'a donc en même temps et ça coûtera
moins cher et ça a un côté aussi
développement durable aujourd'hui on va
utiliser le bois de goyavier donc ça a
été fabriquée à la main at ease annales
bon on peut pas utiliser vraiment
n'importe quel bois parce que à la
longue ça va pourrir et voilà ça ça va
ramener des mythes que ce soit dans le
jardin ou à la maison donc ça peut être
délicat
me l'a vu faire un 8 âge je vais
continuer mettre à terre re a fait bien
coincé le facile mais à la fin c'est le
résultat du travail heures comme c'est
un travail physique bain mais on est
fier de faire ça on a pris du plaisir et
l'aspect statistique est là